[Music]
well the film has come together just so
beautifully and I want to commend both
of you for creating just such a
beautiful piece of art and um something
that's so layered and um I want to I
want to start there actually and just
talk about the different layers of the
of the film because there's there's so
much going on and and you know a lot of
times when there's those many pieces
they don't always come together but this
seems to come together so well and so
can you talk just a little bit about
kind of the origins of this project and
and writing it and where the inspiration
for this project came from and how you
started you know assembling just the
different parts of the story line okay
thank you you AB um I'm glad they came
together
nicely um I I think the the um the first
idea I had about this film was when I
read the the the result of the
referendum which is 99% for separation
this was the first time I I realized how
um racist uh uh we are and I'm part of
that Community um there's no way that uh
99% of of a Nation would want to succeed
for any other reason this is
definitely uh social reason these people
are they they feel uh they live in their
country but they feel like they're
second class uh
citizens and I remember I felt uh
complicit and I felt like uh this is
partly my fault um because a lot of the
things you see in this film are I see it
in my own home and in my my my uncle's
home my neighbor's home it's is
everywhere around me um but back then I
was not a filmmaker I I I used to fix
airplanes I was an aircraft engineer um
but I used to write a little bit so um I
I've written something in a small piece
of paper and I put it aside um and later
I became a filmmaker um and um this was
always something that I I wanted to to
to discuss because because I think uh
Sudan's problem has always been its
national identity we try to impose an
Islamic Arabic uh identity on a country
where there's a lot of people who are
not Arabs and a lot of people who are
not Muslims and we are so proud of this
of of things that really don't bring
people together the race religion
gender um and in 2018 when the
revolution sparked uh
um um I only had a like a small synopsis
but it made me
very
um it gave me confidence to take on such
a sensitive topic because the people
were outside on the streets they were
calling for Change and they were finally
calling for things that I think can
bring people together they were calling
for peace for justice for coexistence
for these are things that we can all
share um but this is the political side
um
when I wrote draft one it was mainly
plot like this woman who's not really
identified H from the north that's all
she hits this child and then she feels
guilty so she brings uh the his mom to
live with her and to work as a mate but
um the the characters were not so
defined and I kind of felt this and AMJ
also was talking about this and um I
think from draft two onwards I I tried I
I started
to uh pull a lot from from my own
experience I I was I was a very
different person 20 years ago I was just
like Akram in the film like exactly um
the same kind of racism the this
misogyny oh that bad it's you were you
never you haven't met me no I met you 10
years ago it's 20 years ago yeah okay 20
years ago so we were so bad that you
okay but then I I traveled outside uh I
traveled to Jordan to study uh Aviation
engineering and suddenly those
privileges that I I had in Sudan does
not apply outside U and I started to
slowly have different ideas different
thoughts um and I I kind of um the more
Progressive thoughts you have the less
you can openly discuss them in a
conservative U uh Society so uh uh for
me uh it it it was like a I'm becoming a
better person but I always be I also
picked habit of
flying um so it it's this is MAA this is
me five years five years later so um and
also because I back by then I knew I
wanted to switch to Art From engineering
from this mentality of thinking in terms
of right and wrong 01 this binary
engineer mindset is has also started to
sh shift to to an artist's uh mindset
where there is no rights there's no
wrongs everything is a matter of
perspective and if uh an empathy um you
can also find that the mo quest to
pursue uh singing uh is also my quest to
switch from engineering to to to artist
to to Art which wasn't easy in my
community because they they don't think
of be being a filmmaker as something
prestigious you know you're you're
you're an engineer so I started putting
a lot of that in the in the script and
yeah by draft 10 this is what you have
it's interesting because I think um for
me the the film it's um it's political
but it it's also very personal so even
to hear you share that I can see you
know some of them very literal in terms
of that that that personal element that
comes through to you know comes through
in the film but you know I think that um
you really strike a really great balance
between the the political and the
personal I remember reading the script
and uh and even more so watching it and
just going oh no like every it's like
every all of these decisions that Mona
makes and these circumstances that she
finds herself in is kind of like a
spiral that it just keeps getting worse
and worse and it's just like oh my God
and so you get so wrapped up in her
story and also of course Julia's story
as well and that was going to be one of
my questions is is you know was that
intentional it sounds like it was a
little bit organic and um you know with
some intentionality as
well yeah um I
think what my
intentions was always to uh put all my
characters in the gray area
and you can maybe disagree with what
they're doing but you would understand
why they're doing the things they're
doing even akam um you you I empathized
with myself 20 years ago because I
consider myself a victim of my community
uh a victim of how I was raised and a
victim of the Traditions that are passed
on from generation to generation we just
accept them
dogmatically um
so I I think for reconciliation I think
the film is about reconcilation iation
for reconciliation the the best thing
that can happen is that if we understand
one another if we we don't have to agree
on the first time we sit together but at
least if if I
understand why you choose to do the
things you do maybe then forgiveness
becomes a uh easy and Reconciliation
becomes easy uh so I wanted to take that
to the extreme is Mona you uh I wanted
to take her to um somewhere where she
had to finally break down sit on the
floor and know that she cannot continue
in that path
anyway and then I'm Jad as the producer
of this film can you talk a little bit
about first first how you connected with
Muhammad how did that relationship come
to be and kind of what that process was
like as the producer in terms of
crafting the story and then if you can
also talk about production wise cuz I
know you had had several challenges I
know when you were part of the
fellowship it was there were a lot of
questions
about you you know anyway uh yeah me and
mo actually I think uh I was doing that
uh film festival in Sudan uh since
2013 and we were looking for filmmakers
and there is no sudane a lot of Sudanese
filmmakers you know everyone maybe I
don't know if you know that like Cinema
Sudan is stopped by the Islamic
government in
1989 and then like 20 years like really
more more than 20 years maybe 30 years
but let's say 20 years till the 19 uh s
200 um 18 started Sudan film Factory
started to some filmmakers that
workshops then I heard about about uh
this engineer who came from bahin with
his money that he collected all the year
to do a short film and back again uh you
know to edit there and bahin with
himself doing one man show I saw his
first short film uh D out gold gun for
gold and and I like it and then I sent
it I sent to him uh and then we KN we
knew each other from that time actually
and then he did this uh the film after
it's called ner cook and I was I was in
love with that film and uh we've been
traveling together by coincidence with
two films to JCC Tunisia Cartage and he
won an award there uh with that film and
uh yeah and then uh he told me about
this idea of uh goodbye Julia that he
wanted to do uh as a future film but
with like4
$50,000 $20,000 yeah initially I wanted
to make the for $20,000 us to do it like
show collect from his you know his
savings and come you know and like
please please let don't handle the
camera you you don't have to edit it
let's collect money and just make it
properly someone else will be working
with you there is some people called
editors someone else called doop by the
way not not necessarily
you so so yeah but also I was so busy
doing you diet 20 and and it was a
chance for him to develop the script so
I just invited him to be with me on set
and he will die at 20 in
2018 December 2018 so you you diet 20
was a was your directed by me and co-
directed and co-produced by you and the
station filmed the company uh we started
with real die 20 because we don't have
cinema company there that time so we
started that uh time and then we decided
like our next film it will be goodby
Julia definitely and uh yeah and at the
beginning he told me like um uh let's
hire a a script writer do you remember
that I was like why man you do posst in
Facebook like 1,000 share people love
what you write and and I think this is
your idea let's give it a try at least
you know and he did and actually it was
amazing the first draft sure not the the
one to go to shoot with but it's
obviously for you for me I was like hey
I remember I told you like you should
write my next
film um so so I think I started that
time we did the first uh pitching in
Portugal Portugal in yeah spinu in
2019 in May during I was doing uh the
post- production you will die 20 then
you will die 20 another Sudanese films
came out in 2019 it was a big year for
actually Sudanese Cinema and from that
time we start announcing goodbye Julia
we start developing uh uh production
wise and script wise in
development um development Workshop as
film independent so I think I think uh
it it it took a journey and I think it
was very useful for the script writer
for the director and also for the
production and then earlier you were
telling us just about the you know the
support from from the government in
Sudan can you talk a little bit about
just that process of filming there no
you were asking me outside if if they
harassing us and I was telling every
actually no because one year before that
they did a like a Cup on the government
that we like you know so I think they
were trying to tell everyone or at least
uh you know filmmakers and artists like
we are not bad we are supporting so they
give us the permission but without even
asking for the script you know it was
like maybe they know like something
wrong going to happen because we
finished shooting in December and the
and the the Water started in April so
maybe inside there they know like they
want to recruit uh you know young uh
People Like Us with them and somehow
also the script was a little bit
different yeah you know that that the
secrets of directors with sending the
script for for for government you you
never send the right script I mean that
part of the world at
least um you have to be honest on that
actually because you would got like
no but actually the Govern had better
things to worry about because we shot
right after the coup we started shooting
we started uh preparing and there was a
lot of protests uh they would like um
block the streets uh no internet no um
they they they were so uh scared of um
people gathering together so we had to
deal with that as well because we can't
get from one location to another because
they're blocking all the roads so
sometimes we would uh know what were
shooting today on the day so the first
ad would um check the internet because
that that's where the the protesters
would announce the the roots for the
protests um so we would wait to see that
and then we would decide okay today we
can only shoot in this location and that
location so go prepare the Wardrobe
prepare the we do this in the morning of
the day this is directing site
production site we had to have the the
the schedule and we have to have we had
also to have have all the people even
the Sudanese people living in one hotel
so imagine for independent film like you
you are like U Rent a full uh Hotel
apartments for everyone coming from
outside like we have people from Tunisia
Lebanon South Africa and sudanes you
know they're just the like the the the
head of departments from outside and uh
some head of departments from Sudan also
everyone was living together because
it's safer for us to control and to to
take them to the location without being
inage on the closed roads and yeah wow
wow yeah that sounds like a a production
quite a production um feet for a prod
yeah it was something but also um C has
started a company there Clum colosium uh
with his partner khed a and khed already
is they are working like weekly
even during the revolution and stuff
like ads or documentaries and so in
somehow they knows how to navigate the
things in cartoon so I think that helped
a lot yeah yeah also I must say that the
crew which is mostly Sudanese like we
had a few Foreigner crew like uh 10
people maybe but the rest are all
Sudanese uh because of the military coup
this film to them was part of the
Revolution it was part of protesting so
uh um making the film is for them is a
protest so if if if it wasn't like this
we would never be able to to shoot this
film but every day they wake up and
they're so adamant and and persistent
and and determined to to to make things
work so this Spirit really uh help uh
creating this project so I have to ask
you the the film is beautiful like
visually um very well done and I'm
curious what were some of your um
Inspirations or or maybe even more
specifically if you can just talk about
kind of what you were um looking to
accomplish visually especially I I was
really struck by um you know the way you
film there some of the there's some of
the scenes with Julia and Mona in
particular like there's this really cool
really interesting way you kind of
juxtapose them in space and how they're
framed I think there's one uh frame
where Mona is um
she's it's almost like she's conf almost
looks like she's in a confessional Booth
um so maybe you can talk just a little
bit about kind of how you what was some
of your inspiration for um filming it um
I I love the 4x3 for this project it
just felt right uh to shoot in
4x3 um first of all because it's
claustrophobic and I wanted that feel to
um to be present in the house house that
feels like a like a
prison
um but this was not an easy choice
because uh I wanted to make this film
accessible to more people and 4x3 is not
exactly the most popular uh aspect
ratio um but I I had to
um work on the image and make it pretty
uh to kind of balance that
uh so we we we me and Pierre the
cinematographer we worked for like two
months before we started shooting and
every day we would have a meeting of
three or four hours to discuss how to
make things look and the beauty of 4x3
is that it allows you to to play with uh
to layer your your image like you can
have someone in the foreground someone
in the background someone in the middle
and the person in the foreground would
still be it can be medium uh composition
of them it's not like the um that
cinemascope you'll only have the head
probably if you want to layer people in
the and we wanted to play that you You'
see that in the in the scene of the
staircase when you uh Akram stops MAA
and Julia and starts talking to them uh
and you you get the feeling that Akram
is between the two and um this is just
the composition and then again when uh
Aram starts searching mun's phone and
then he calls Julia it's also that
triangle uh composition style and this
is all possible because of the 4x3 uh in
terms of lighting I wanted the house to
to feel dark cuz it for me it's like a
cave and there's all the sun all the
light outside is 2 m away if she if she
just opens the door there's an abundance
of light but they choose to live in that
uh space so I wanted to work a lot with
shadow but see that light coming through
the window so many of the scenes you get
that feeling that there's so much sun
outside yeah it's it's it's dark inside
it almost felt like a thriller in some
places like I was there was it it
created its own tension I felt and I
thought that that was very very well
done can you talk a little bit about the
music in the film I thought that the
music was was interesting were those
songs that Mona sang I think I believe
she sang a couple couple of songs in it
one at the church one at the end and
then there was another one that she sang
at the yeah she she s two and she tried
to sing one but she didn't she only
played uh the
inter um the the music is an integral
part of this film in my opinion and we
didn't uh use plenty of score I think we
only have like two scenes with scores
and the rest of it is is actual uh uh
songs that's either part of the of the
scene or is being sung by the by the
characters in the film and and I think
what helped is that I worked with the
same music producer for both so he's the
composer and the music producer for the
song so we kind of struck the balance
between uh because I I didn't want to
use um a lot of score because I think it
kind of takes away from the realism feel
that I'm going for every time I play
music it feels like um the realism goes
less uh while the the music if it's
being played from a radio it's being
played from from a TV or someone is
singing that's that's part of the of the
scene so in our meeting before we
started working we said uh which scenes
will definitely need uh score and we
just pointed them out and for the rest
we worked on the songs and the songs
really uh celebrate our culture because
um it might seem like I'm I'm I'm
criticizing a lot of uh our Traditions
but at the same time I'm celebrating a
very rich culture be it uh northerner or
Southerner there's also uh music from
South Sudan and music from North Sudan
and um it's it's it's just my way of
saying that we have so much to to
celebrate and and a lot of it is due to
diversity had you worked with these
actors before either of you no this is
their first time acting uh in front of a
camera so um both of them are uh this is
their first experience and
um um I I found them uh both on social
media uh but we did a bit of rehearsing
of course before the the film and we did
table rates and um but yes it's it's
their first time
acting um
I know we're running out of running out
of time but
amjad what has been the reaction to the
film and what is what what's next for
goodbye
Julia
um the the premere actually it was like
amazing when uh when we just announced
in 13 April uh 13th of April we
announced the film in can and then 14 15
April 15th of April the war started in
Sudan so we got two days to to to jump
on and be happy and then the film in can
uh was really uh aeit there and people
were talking about it all the time and
then at the end of the the festival we
won the freedom award which is almost
the script award they change the names
of the award this year uh it was it was
great to have the film there in can for
the first time for Sudanese film to be
there uh after that the film did very
well well in festivals maybe till now
like we have 18th a 18th award I'm more
always excited about the audin award of
it because we have six audience awards
from different Europe two days ago from
Singapore um so this is really means
something you know especially because I
think both we want it all the time you
know how Cinema there in U that part of
the world it's mostly like U independent
indie film this is for festival and that
that's it we wanted to say no it could
be more especially when uh for example
now the film in Egypt uh now entering
the the second month no not entering say
third month we are in two months now in
Egyptian Cinema and that's very
difficult in Egypt it's just like
American films or Egyptian films so to
have a FM uh without stars that they
know but also maybe because a lot of
Sudanese people uh immigrate now to
Egypt you know after the war uh but also
in France today we're entering the
seventh uh week in France in French
Cinemas wonderful yeah for like 70 or 80
cinemas around France uh it is doing
very well now also in Gulf area Dubai um
Saudi Arabia Kuwait bahin we started uh
this week or yeah this second week yeah
we theatrically released into Gulf last
week and we're releasing in Dubai
particular after exactly so so it's
surprising us and actually people there
in AR the critics that are writing about
this is supposed to be uh something a
case study actually how this film could
mix between being taken Awards in
festivals and also playing very well
with odinist so we happy with that yes
any Us distribution in there just yet
hopefully hopefully uh we have no here
our disciplin from uh uh ENT light and
also ca ca is my agent and they are
helping in distributing with amp light
and we just have uh Lita nango she's she
fall in love with the film like uh the
past month and she she's she join she
joined us as executive producer uh we're
very happy having her you know part of
the campaign of the Oscar but also
having lupan yangu actually one day when
we were thinking about Julia Lita's face
was something like a reference you know
or something we thought about it so blow
of
Attraction exactly love the attraction
and suddenly Lita is ex producer of the
film so yeah we are very happy with
those steps U selling in new you know I
always heard like people here they don't
they don't like to read uh subtitle what
is that rumors is that true anyway we'll
try it maybe maybe not right so uh let's
see I hope like uh if we move forward to
the short list maybe the map will be
different for Distributing the film in
us it's a great film thank you again for
for making it and for bringing it here
and congratulations on all of your
success and just such a well-made film
and so I think you guys make a great
team so keep making keep making movies
thank you every thank you thank you
everyone
[Music]